oh
cute kim kardashian and pete davidson
kiss in our matching blondes in videos
she posted to her instagram story on
sunday
along with this shot of them kissing kim
took to social media to share this video
of pete whispering in her ear as she
blushes away and this black and white
video of the couple rocking black shades
while sticking their tongue out rockstar
style
it's always so much fun kim and pete's
latest pda moment comes after pete made
his first low-key appearance following
his exit from snl after eight years
on friday the comedian was spotted
outside of kim's calabasas office
rocking a shower cap over his newly
bleached blonde hair
peter is giving a thumbs up in the shot
while kim seemingly worked on a photo
shoot speaking of thumbs up last week
caitlyn jenner raved about kim and
pete's relationship on the pivot podcast
we need a comedian in the family
we don't need more rappers we need
comedians in the family
as she revealed her thoughts on how pete
compares to kim's estranged ex-husband
kanye west pete is 180 degrees the other
direction and what it was like meeting
pete for the first time first of all he
treats her so well
and when they were over here
kim is so happy
and kim deserves to be happy
she's been through a hell of a lot in
her life a hell of a lot you know and
she deserves happiness
kim and pete have been dating since
october and recently a source told e.t
that pete is ready to take his
relationship with kim to the next level
saying quote kim and peter doing great
she definitely foresees a strong healthy
and promising future with him he is so
respectful of her and treats her like an
absolute queen he is completely enamored
by her beauty and talent adding quote he
thinks she's an awesome mom and would
more than likely take their relationship
to the next level in a heartbeat
he's just super genuine when easy spoke
to kim in april she revealed what it is
about dating pete that has her smitten
it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do
nothing that's my favorite thing
it's the best because you can do
everything with totally but it's crazy
to be distracted with people you can be
with anyone
distracted but you can't be with anyone
and do nothing just yeah
running errands
[Music]